hello everyone this is amir from audio science
review welcome to another episode of inside uh
your high resolution music this is by request
again to look at the free samples that
the linn records provides for free so feel free
to go to this url and download and play with
the same files there are three tracks here i've
downloaded the highest quality available which is
192 kilohertz uh 24-bit uh samples i have
brought those into adobe audition and i'm
going to go ahead and play these for you
one at a time and let's see what we discover
so oops let me get this to be at the beginning
so there we go pausing this uh it's a piano
piece we immediately see usual problems uh
these ultrasonic tones are there uh four over my
count interesting enough the frequency is actually
different in different channels blue is one
channel red is the other channel and so they're
actually picking up different frequencies rather
than the same frequencies so different problems
there i don't have an explanation for them
again they could be crt monitor scans and
other ultrasonic sources in the environment
other than that we have a slightly rising
noise floor which is some kind of noise
shaping happening not not much to talk about
but but it's there um playing the track again
we see that piano really doesn't have
much of a spectrum as ultrasonics go
i'd say it's about 20 20 20 kilos to 25 kilohertz
looking at the heat map we see that above
about this level or so it's all black
so there's really no spectrum in here
so this could have been sampled at 88 kilohertz uh
without any problems and at 88 kilohertz we would
have cut off at 44 kilos here not have any of this
rising nose floor or these peaks so uh same story
as other music that we've examined disappointing
that these are there fortunate levels are not
so extreme but the frequencies are quite high so
let's move on to the second track they provided
and again let me pull this to
the beginning and let's play that
immediately we see the issues rising out
of the noise floor this is an organ piece
uh i can't see any reason for this to be there
this and the other peaks let it continue to play
so we see the usual problems peaks in here
not lower frequencies are more bothersome
so this is 26 kilohertz this beak is there this
one's there notice it's just in one channel again
not in the other channel likewise we have one
channel here picking up some garbage here and
not in the other one uh moving this to the end
let's see what happens when there's silence
oops so again even during silence we have
all these peaks uh it's just disappointing
how common this problem is clearly there's just
no attention paid to uh cleaning up ultrasonic
uh people probably just listen to the clips and
if they don't hear something they go ahead and
record and produce this content and ship it
to us more hygiene is definitely necessary
let's go to the third clip the third
clip and see what's going on there
it's quite fascinating here check out
the scalloping uh comb filtering type
of response this isn't that's in here we've got
one here here here here here and it continues on
uh i just can't tell you what's causing
that um unless this is the uh response
of the anti-aliasing filter and it's actually
some of this signal here that's showing up here
as a lower amount of uh lower amplitude than goes
on here but quite unusual it's not something i've
seen in recordings before so let's continue
to play there's really no doubt that this
is all there and you know it's not correlated
with music when music comes it overwhelms it
but as it's there as a background sort of
tones that keep going on and on we have our usual
rising nose floral so uh because of noise shaping
what this southern peak was yeah it looks
like there's actually musical information
the microphone has pretty good bandwidth and
he's trying to struggle and to push above
this noise floor if this rising noise floor
wasn't there and we didn't have this garbage
this is a quite a wide bandwidth uh recording
as far as the microphones are concerned
so pulling this all the way to the end and
see what happens during the silence again
again we see all this statically there so
definitely definitely not good uh disappointing
on multiple fronts you know in addition to
the usual peaks that we have now we have this
tons of spectrum over here that scallops up and
down uh some of these are awfully close to the
audible band i mean check out this one it's right
at 20 kilohertz even this one might be suspect so
you know this is supposed to be silence and
instead we have this all the way down to 14
15 kilohertz something is generating this
spray of harmonics uh yeah thinking about
this may actually be a switching power
supply of some sort maybe powering uh
some amplifiers something in the signal path
that's generating all this it could also even
be their lighting system actually thinking
about it out loud could be some kind of
switching power supply that's powering led lights
of the sword that's generating all of this noise
i definitely wouldn't call
this high resolution music so
have these offered as a sample of what high
resolution music could provide is disappointing
subjectively none of this sounds like
it needs high resolution piano music and
vocals and and organ wouldn't be my choice if
something that that needs ultra high spectrum
i know there's some arguments about timing
resolution what have you we'll leave that to
a future episode but again disappointing um
for samples i expect to see pristine and clean
musical samples provided to us not stuff
that looks like this so that's it again
this is Amir from audiosciencereview.com
talk to you later in a future video bye-bye